well let's jump into this first story we
got this from The Daily Caller you may
have seen the news earlier today doj
searches Biden's Delaware home for a
second time searches just a search not a
raid no it's only a raid when you're
going after your political enemies right
because Joe Biden basically is the doj
they're just searching his uh his house
so uh here's what I want to point out we
we had we titled this his home's rated
because that's what they say of Donald
Trump they say his home was rated right
and it's like Donald Trump was
cooperating with them letting them come
in go through everything that they went
there twice they went to the first time
said put a lock on I said okay then they
come back break the lock off take the
documents and you didn't cooperate and
it's like he was but the media does that
thing yeah where if Trump does it it's
evil if Biden does it it's no big deal
no big deal isn't his Daily Caller and
he's still calling it search and that's
my point when I'm reading the post
millennial and and even the
post-millennial called antifa domestic
terrorists protesters I'm like come on
oh my gosh Libby was here and I told her
I'm like Libby what are you doing she's
like I know I know and then there was
even even uh on timcast.com we an
article was put up where it referred to
them as protests and I'm like they're
not they're being charged with domestic
terrorism so Joe Biden has the FBI go to
his house and say it was a planned
search why is the FBI searching the home
of the sitting president for illegally
held classified documents what is this
the fourth the fourth search of his
properties to be fair you know they've
had a 100 success rate so far they they
rated his first home definitely found
documents now have to check the beach
house and see if he left anything there
they didn't find anything yeah I know
but like it's worked for them in the
past we can't trust that he hasn't I
mean Biden spends an enormous amount of
time at these two properties it's not
surprising I am surprised that they
didn't check it sooner right and I would
only object to the term search I think
possibly you could say it's a search
because I'm sure the Biden
Administration knew about it beforehand
whereas I don't think the same courtesy
was extended to Trump when they raided
Mar-A-Lago right yeah is it active
aggression the search is like hey just
so you know we're coming don't forget to
move that stuff in your garage yeah and
also uh before for this before the
entire Trump debacle the FBI had very
low trust with the American people so
they're probably trying to make the FBI
look more credible again possibly that's
a good point could be one of their
motives for sure what was their reason
for uh going to his house anyway the
Delaware house did they have like a
reasonable cause there's probable cause
for for something being there or was it
just like they're calling it a search
yeah right I think it's because he owns
two properties in Delaware one at
Rehoboth Beach and one in Wilmington the
Wilmington is where they found the
documents for so now they get to check
the other place where he spends a lot of
time one of the weekends where they were
searching his house he just went to his
other house in Delaware right like these
are places that he spends an enormous
amount of time so if he is doing
something he's not supposed to do
documents it makes sense that you would
check both properties it would be weird
to leave one off the list I feel like
every president would have classified
documents in their homes I mean and like
what is it we talked about this one time
like what is a classified document is it
like a menu from a millionaire because
at one point those were classified side
I don't know I mean it is weird they
were in his garage and whereas Trump had
his like stored in the appropriate way
but I mean I think it's cover-up yeah I
mean the spin is is interesting I think
that says a lot and I feel like this
headline in particular if you're not
aware that I keep saying this but
because he has two homes in Delaware
they're like they checked his Delaware
home there's nothing there it sort of
canceled out the headlines from a couple
weeks ago where it was like well we
checked his Delaware home and there were
documents I think here's what I'm
thinking
why did why why are they going after
bidening these documents but Biden's
legal team I think is legal aids are the
ones who actually informed the FBI that
had the documents whereas with Trump
they raid it's a legal issue imagine
this you're Joe Biden and you want to
dig up dirt on a political opponent your
principal political opponent or your
Merit Garland Garland basically Biden
says oh won't someone rid me of this
Trump and Merrick Garland goes I know
exactly what you're saying he then goes
and says let's go raid Trump's house
we're going to use the the documents you
know the the what was the the law what
is the National Archives actor whatever
that law is record keepings act or
something and they're going to use that
as the pretext to stop Trump from
running from Trump running in 2024 and
then Merrick Garland says but hold on if
this is going to work we got to make
sure Biden doesn't have the same problem
yeah he's got to be clean so then he
orders the search of Biden's property
not because he's targeting Biden because
he's helping Biden I see so trying to
make Trump look worse and if Biden gets
out of office and then they did the
raids it would annihilate like the Biden
name it would make him they'd be like
look you've got all the same things you
Hypocrites so they're just getting out
of the way is that what you're saying
they when they re when they raided his
house the first time no one knew this
was in November they covered it up they
they they no one knew what happened okay
so I'm thinking you know we were talking
about this last week like why would why
would they go after buying is the Deep
State trying to remove him like ending
his 20 24 chances maybe it could be both
it could be this
they know Joe Biden can't run 2024 he's
not going to win yeah they also don't
want Trump to run and he will win what
do you do oh oh geez oh Biden you broke
the record keeping you can't run for
president now oh man that means Trump
can't run either oh and then if Trump
tries to rumble but hey look we even
stopped biding for money because we're
being fair
interesting so he's like there's
sacrificial lamb yeah well I mean
there's also like a lot of infighting
going on with the Democrats regarding
Biden whether he should be the one to
run in 2024 or should they replace him
but after the midterms it seemed like
Biden's approval rating went up so they
stopped with the you know anti-biting
stuff for a while but I don't know maybe
this will change things I mean he said
he would announce after Christmas right
we're after Christmas he has not
announced and I think that can only tell
you that he wants to run yeah and they
don't want it's going to be a
progressive it might not be a little guy
who who could I think that's their
biggest issue they don't have a clear
front runner I know people have said
Newsome I know people say Kamala but
like Kamal is not likable the quality is
not like well her her always have always
been lower than bidens and that's saying
something over at predict it you can buy
there's a it's a prediction Market thing
for those guys for those that don't know
you buy shares in in a concept so it's
like who will be the Democrats 2024
nominee and you can buy one share of
Kamala Harris yes for nine cents that
means if you buy a share for nine cents
and she does become the nominee you get
a dollar or like a dollar ten or
something like that and that's a
tremendous that's a ten to one return
right
but come on no sane person thinks she's
gonna be the nominee yeah I don't know
why people are buying shares in Kamal
hairs but here's the best part you can
buy no she won't be for 91 cents now
that means for every 91 cents you spend
when she invariably is not the the
nominee you get nine cents that sounds
like free money to me I'm not giving
Financial advice I'm just saying it's
kind of crazy where
there's no way I it's going to be really
funny in 2024 when or 2023 who knows
when they're like I'm here's the nominee
and I'm just like wow I could not did
not see that coming I gotta tell you man
if someone asked me to to make a large
wager a large sum of money
on whether or not Kamala Harris would be
the nominee I'd say no
this is not going to happen do you guys
think that in 2036 there will be a
United States
or that we will have a president that
will be able to have a pro you think
that will be structurally sound enough
yeah it'd be like four elections from
from coming or something it depends if
you know there's a Civil War coming or
not I wonder because I'm like we talk
about if we just sit here and wait is it
going to become like dude if we just sit
here and wait the world's gonna blow
itself up we have to like actively
change the system uh I can't I can't
wait for idiot a or idiot B to become
the next leader anymore I'm concerned
that if we just if we just play games
and watch it like a TV show that
the inevitable demise of the American
way is is around the corner I hate to
make a bet but I do think that they're
in 13 years that
that feels far right now but it's really
not in the span of time anyone who's in
their 60s will probably tell you that
like 13 years can go by really quickly I
feel like probably there's a country I
would not be surprised if the party
system looks different and that might be
wishful thinking on my part but I think
it might be a little bit yeah but I
think that there's so much like the the
criticism Democrats and the left-leaning
media always love yet Republicans is
that they're they're in fighting and
they don't get along but the same thing
is true for the left right and I think
as the youngest generation ages into
being a solid voter block you know they
are the most likely to cross lines on
tickets right if you ask them how they
feel about different issues it doesn't
all fall in one Camp so again wishful
thinking on my part but I don't think
the parties as we know them today
necessarily will be where be the same in
13 years I do think it's gonna get worse
it's going to get more Progressive on on
the Democrat side on the Republican side
too but they'll leave people behind yeah
they both will leave people behind like
we talk about this with like the
shrinking middle class like what if
politics gives way to a solid middle
class and that means ideology not
financially block of Voters right the
people who don't feel like they have a
home in the Republican party or uh the I
don't think the two-party system is
going to change anytime soon I mean the
Republicans and Democrats they've
collaborated and colluded to make sure
that never happens
um they've pretty much stopped
independent candidates from getting on
the debate stage I mean the last time
was Ross Perot that's never going to
happen again unless you know the
American people wake up I don't see that
happening anytime soon unless there is
some sort of Civil War so
I think the clearest sign would be if we
had more independent Governors I've not
thought that for a while because Oregon
ran an independent who got a fair amount
of votes she didn't win they let the the
Democrat went in but I do think that
like yes you're right it's just like
administratively it seems really hard to
imagine a non-to-party system but I just
don't think I mean it's not in our
constitution or anything it's not
possible it's just the way things have
worked out right but I just think that
young voters are more likely to leave
the idea of like you have to be one or
the other behind
it's hard though because there are
states where you have to register with a
party to vote in that primer right and
that will be a difficult system to
change well according to polling I think
48 to 50 percent of Americans are
independent but then those Independents
end up voting either Republican or
Democrat when push comes because you
have to to participate in the primaries
you have to be in the party yeah and in
the general I'm talking about but as
more as that gets left behind like if we
were to reverse States like there are so
many states that you have to do that and
there are other states that don't want
that if we didn't have to identify in
the primaries I think you would see a
shift on the actual platform again
wishful thinking of my part but or maybe
it has to be a top-down approach maybe
maybe it needs to start on the national
level it needs to start in the
presidential election for it to trickle
down yeah I mean it'd be really
interesting yeah thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time